how are you finding balancing the acting
career with the music part for me at
school well I just been sacrificing to
sleep more than anything I'm just
getting on with it I don't want to be
one of those you know one of those I
guess artists or entertainers that here
constantly moaning are I'm tired and
keeping busy only I mean you were in
this film
cockney vs. zombies with Michelle Ryan
but this isn't that this is the first
time we were in together and you're also
in another film for the man inside which
kind of came out before that but she
recommended you for the roles in change
yeah yes she did I'm the man inside was
the first time I actually worked with
Michelle I worked of hour-long class one
four three two one then this and then
one this one really good I got to speak
and you know just got to know each other
she was really cool really got on and it
she suggested me for the role for the
man inside and then and then that's a
couple really roles as well so like yeah
I'm really thankful to resharpen like is
a good part how do the experience differ
working on the dip in the various films
with her yeah it's cool never never been
very characters man I mean then this one
she's like a kick-ass chick and the
other film that we learned the man
inside she's really vulnerable and that
quiet agree in this film and these meds
on me I'm not kick ass dude and in in
the man inside I'm really vulnerable man
so you know we've had different dynamics
to play a rather character in cockneys
vs. zombies is called mental Mickey and
some one of the characters says it's not
easy mentally just has anger management
issues how did you psych yourself up to
get into that role I just um I would do
two hours of makeup every morning and
get the scar put on my head get the go
to put in my mouth forget the tattoo on
my neck I was in the gym I was feeling
strong so I was just I was in the mode
already physically to the student role
so as soon as I was on set I was just
ready to go
what makes you angry in real life not as
the character mental beekeeper in real
life as Ashley Thomas two things people
that say no or I can't because I know
that it can't be done I'm just um you
know bullies and stuff I'm not really in
some winnings I just think why would you
like see your acting career go for me
actually just just building really from
Jeff just have taken on new challenges
with characters and just you know not
really play the same roles just like
switch it up change up all the time in
bigger features with more money I guess
and then still do grit flicks and
independent films and it's like you know
mix aren't there any directors or actors
you'd like send a shout-out to you'd
love to work with
I want to work with Ross Smith that's my
guy
I'm a shy about every interview that's
my guy and so I'm working from yeah that
was me well you got the music down the
acting guy on just like whoo yeah yeah I
guess I guess like you know if we go for
that 50% of his success will be good
this next video what P look forward to
it over LAN bish bash Bosh just yeah I
just keep it up to date with me at bash
calm and to Armour your inner you've got
a part in my brother's devil haven't you
I think coming up brilliant film as well
you're better than me you're better than
me you know what you know more about me
than I do yeah have my brother the devil
that comes out I think in November and
the man inside comes out on December
24th on DVD wheezing wise what are you
working on at the moment I'm just
finished my EP is called the Great
Escape that comes out when a free
download are announced that vomits wits
are which is that battery and I'm
working on my second album apparently
Richard fingers crossed we are next
years in the demo stages right now but
everything sound I'm really good you're
positive
you